good afternoon welcome to this
roundtable discussion challenges to
security and stability in Central and
East Europe building new European
security architecture my name is Bradley
Woodworth and here in the McMillan
center i coordinate yells programming in
Baltic Studies so it's my pleasure to
introduce the participants of the round
table today first we'll be speaking his
ex and his Excellency ambassador on
today's building or bridge he is the
permanent representative of the Republic
of Latvia to the United Nations
mr. peel decor which began his countries
became his country's ambassador to the
UN in September 2018 before this
appointment he served from 2013 as state
secretary in latias Ministry of Foreign
Affairs from 2007 to 2012 he was
ambassador to the United States and we
met in that role in some capacity he's
held various positions in the office of
the president of Latvia also in Latvia
'z Ministry of Foreign Affairs a
beginning in 1994 Latvia is a leader in
information and cybersecurity in Europe
and ambassador P legal resident is an
active member of the UN group of friends
on eat governance and cybersecurity next
we'll hear from mr. bubble or Adamski
mr. Adamski is deputy permanent
representative of the Republic of Poland
to the United Nations he was part of the
team that helped Poland become elected
as non permanent member of the UN
Security Council for 2018-2019 he has
represented Poland in numerous debates
at the UN Security Council on topics
including peace and security in Europe
conflict prevention and children in
armed conflict he's an active
participant in UN debates and
discussions on other topics such as
disarmament and human rights
ambassador UD sir gave is a senior
fellow here at the Macmillan Center and
we must thank him for putting this whole
round table together he served as
ukraine's ambassador to the united
nations from 2007 to 2016 probably do
that he served as ambassador to Greece
in Albania ambassador to France in
UNESCO and his first deputy deputy
minister state secretary
Ukraine's Ministry of Foreign Affairs
his experience related to service in the
UN is vast I'll just mention his work as
vice chairman of the peace building
commission from 2011 to 2012 and then he
was an elected member of the UN Security
Council in 2016 and 2017 he was an
academic prior to entering government
service from 1981 to 1992 he was a
professor philology at Tara's Shevchenko
State University and in addition to his
work here at Yale ambassador gave us
continued his academic work as a
visiting professor at the United Nations
Institute for training and research and
so Yuri you will be moderating so I'll
turn the time over to you
Thank You Brett thank you for hosting
roundtables on particular on these
important issues the security stability
in the region of the central Eastern
Europe and of course in the region where
you are expert in professor Bradley is
one of the leading experts in the United
States on Estonia speaks fluent Estonian
he knows literature whatever and today
he will not only be a host but I expect
him to contribute something from the
American historian point of view on the
on the issue I'd well advise all our
panelists the gas here to present
briefly their vision from their
perspective on the building of new
architectural security in Europe and a
youthful first to immersive Latvia
alphabetic order United Nations
principle that protocol as well yeah
please you have a floor
ambassador thank you so much for
inviting me back to Yale it's a pleasure
to visit this remarkable University
after eight year interval and to reflect
on what we have achieved since our last
discussion a few years ago and I also
want to think thank from the start
professor kegui and all supporters of
the Baltic Studies here at this
university it's really very important
and timely contribution to our
transatlantic debate and to our
transatlantic ties I want to first
mention a few important dates to give
the context for our discussion we just
finished celebration of the centennial
of the Baltic States last November
Latvia was the last country to mark
centennial of the modern Latin
Democratic Republic in a few weeks we
will mark 70th anniversary of the NATO
alliance the probably the most
successful most efficient alliance in
the history of the human kind and this
anniversary coincides with the 15th
anniversary of the Latvian and Baltic
membership in the lines I also want to
mention that euro has passed 20th
anniversary and that coincides with the
fifth anniversary of the Latvian
membership in in the common European
currency so those anniversaries they
give a quite quite good platform to
reflect what is right what has been done
correctly what is missing what are the
challenges and and opportunities for for
the future I probably will not surprise
you being a cold war baby a person which
has witnessed at the students times
collapse of the Soviet Union I am I am a
false believer in the correctness and
the rightness of the concept of Europe
whole free and at peace we've been
building this Europe for the
almost 30 years and I think that this is
a very sound and very credible
foundation for the future European
architecture which is fully anchored
first of all within NATO as the pillar
and as a foundation cornerstone of the
European and transatlantic security
architecture we fully believe that NATO
is existential transatlantic partnership
with the United States with Canada with
Iceland is fundamental for the future of
European can continent and we are
tirelessly working to build this this
foundation we will have the summit at
the end of the year in London to reflect
on this 70th anniversary we certainly in
a very important implementation stage of
the Wales summit decisions of the Warsaw
summit decisions in 2016 we believe that
we are progressing quite nicely on
implementation and enhance forward
presence in the Baltic States and Poland
has been proceeding according to the
plans we we are doing what we had
decided we were building up to necessary
infrastructure necessary command
structures we are building missing
capabilities in the region maritime air
defence air controls we are working a
lot on the interoperability of the of
the NATO allies we are open door policy
remains fundamental in this respect and
we are very pleased at the last country
of the original Vilnius 10 will join the
Alliance shortly and I mean North
Macedonia the protocol has been signed a
few weeks ago and we believe that
further procedures will follow quite
smoothly and we work a lot on so-called
Hyper hybrid threats including
cybersecurity which has been mentioned
in introduction as one of the probably
biggest vulnerabilities of all the
modern world
classical conventional warfare is
probably not a very realistic scenario
overall the region of the Baltic Sea is
probably one of the safest in in the
world one of the most stable in the
world thanks to large extent to the
correct decisions on NATO and EU
enlargements which have eliminated any
element of an credibility the region is
stable in a sense that the borders are
clear there are no open territorial
issues there are very there are no
foreign military bases in the region the
rules of the game are clear to every
country in the region BTU NATO members
or countries like Russia or Belarus
which are which are obviously outside of
the of our transatlantic structures so
just a few words to to conclude that the
policies of the 90s and early decades of
this century we believe have been very
correct we certainly applaud all
Republican and Democratic presidents
which have advanced those goals we
believe that this transatlantic link is
very essential and just to give you
historical perspective
in the 20s and 30s first two decades of
our independence we our leadership of
that time thought that being non-aligned
being neutral will help us to whether
international storms we had thought our
leaders of that time had thought that by
staying outside of the alliances of
security agreements we will be protected
we invest at that time enormous Lee you
know
defense defense budget in the 30s and
20s of the last century was about 20%
but but the country was not very
democratic in the late 30s the
Parliament was disbanded and when we
were faced with ultimatums from the east
and invasions from the West Soviet and
Nazi a very very small number of
politicians were in charge there were no
checks and balances and at the end we
failed miserably with that pre-war
policies we lost one third of the
population
we lost for two decades our statehood de
facto the euro countries continued to
exist
we had embassies in London and
Washington but de facto countries were
under Soviet control and our Soviet
occupation and of course as you know
very well international structures also
were quite ineffective we were members
of League of Nations but those
structures had no any enforcement
mechanisms to stop aggression by Soviet
Union against Finland or Soviet
occupation and against the Baltic States
so we from early 90s we took very clear
and very deliberate decision to be
proactive to be aligned to be active
member of the international collective
security of international organizations
we joined basically every multilateral
structure of the Democratic Western
world including NATO including European
Union OECD and UN of course was the
first institution and we are trying to
to play active role in building this
rule based law based international order
but we are participate in as an example
in minusma operation in Mali one of the
most difficult peace enforcement
operations under the UN Aegis and and
this is our blueprint our Bible of the
of the foreign policy I mentioned a few
times European Union it's for us another
very important existential structure our
British colleagues and friends might
have different opinions about brexit but
for Latvians and I hope I can speak also
on behalf of Lithuanians and Estonians
these are like right and left hands NATO
and European Union equally but when it
comes to security definitely NATO comes
first European Union plays more
complementary role
common European security policy within
European Union has been growing it has
been more articulated since since
implementation of the Lisbon Treaty
over the last ten years but still it is
emerging and the EU 28 or au 27 is still
less a coherent group in terms of the
security policies and we have less
efficient security structures so we
cannot rely fully on them though we are
certainly interested in building more
bridges and interoperability between
NATO and European structures
particularly on intelligence sharing
particularly on facing over the hybrid
threats and and the one
the example of practical implementation
of interpretability is so-called
military Schengen all kind of diplomatic
and diplomatic clearance procedure
arrangements to facilitate movement of
troops movement of military personnel
equipment some capabilities within the
transatlantic space without time delays
and other bureaucratic hindrances we
certainly as I said see considerable
vulnerabilities related to them social
organization of the social media hybrid
hybrid threats cyber threats these
issues are being we have faced as one of
the first countries attacks in
cyberspace as early as 2004 and five in
the Baltics Estonians probably have
heared the brunt of those attacks but we
have seen quite a lot of sophisticated
attacks against our banks against our
government infrastructure and we work a
lot on raising the general awareness of
the member states of the general public
about those vulnerabilities beat
electoral processes beat social media
and centers of excellence in Tallinn and
Riga are quite dedicated to do this work
on cyber and on strategic communications
so we to sum up a little bit we think
that the sound foundations of the
European security architecture are quite
sound NATO and European Union regardless
of what we read in the press or what we
debate in our Parliament's the
foundations are quite quite sounded
solid we are facing
a lot of challenges of course resurgent
Russia rise of China difficult
protracted conflicts in Syria in
Afghanistan of course migration crisis
has been dealt over the last few years
the current members of flow of migrants
is controlled contained but but we
certainly would like to face those
challenges together unity among allies
for us is a very important element and
we committed to both alliances and we
think that we're going to have a good
debate over this year in a few weeks in
Washington during a ministerial meeting
and in December between our leaders
implement think that we probably should
not open Pandora box with a new
strategic concept we better focus on
implementation of the last summit
declarations that may be a very short
introduction to identify some of the
achievements and some of the challenges
with their facing and I look forward for
the for the discussion and thank you
again for inviting me thank you very
much thank you
earlier it was concise but comprehensive
so you pointed some important issues and
I will ask well to be more details on
some of them Sharon Lewis your
experience in all these years and of
course it's good that you mentioned the
history when the u.s. reached the Baltic
States which from the non-aligned status
to be allied as interesting what was the
catalyst for this decision what happened
at the time
so but you'll come back to that you know
I have a pleasure in order to ask to
take you the floor my good friend by
Adamski deputy representative of Poland
to the United Nations and a member of
the Security Council thank you the year
under the end of this year Thank You
ambassador guests you I'm very grateful
and proud to be here at Yale University
my wife is proud of me as well and this
is really great opportunity and honor I
guess mostly to discuss to have chance
to talk about a situation in Europe in
Central and Eastern Europe in security
aspects I would sign fully under
ambassador Wittig of each statement we
sure are I guess the absolute
perspective on on challenges which which
our region faces right now we have the
same really the same approach towards
NATO towards euro and and the problems
which we face from Eastern neighbor
that's what what unites us that
definitely and and shapes our politics
but let me also start with this small
caveat I would say that we are coming
from New York from the UN and it changes
the perspective I spent already five
years in dealing with the with the with
the Security Council mostly and happily
European offers are not in the center of
the Security Council and that's good I
think they we focus on
Middle East on Africa and of course we
regularly are coming back in the
Security Council to the situation in
Ukraine but it serves mostly as
opportunity to to recall to rebuild
awareness of the rest of the world about
the situation not allowed to forget that
the conflict exists that the conflict is
costly in humanitarian dimension and
economic and political but in practice
it doesn't bring much progress and it
doesn't have doesn't creates doesn't
create a chance for this multilateral
involvement from the UN in the in high
degree one one reason of course is veto
power held one by one of the p5 members
and directly interested but so so our
say my remarks on kind of going into the
shoes of my colleagues from Brussels and
from Warsaw when I try to talk about
NATO and European Union but definitely
NATO is the fundamental structure
fundamental organization for Poland for
us it's 20 years since we join together
with Czech Republic and Hungary in 1999
and we are definitely the most
enthusiastic Pro NATO members I would
say together of course with that to
anger Estonia and we see the role of the
NATO as as organization based on the
principle of solidarity article 5 of the
transatlantic trade treaties of crucial
importance for us we also especially now
in this
not easy climate of international
relations we underline the need for for
unity
despite press comments on on divisions
transatlantic divisions we see nato
united we see nato strong and that's the
only way we perceive and with we
approach this this organization and the
third element is ability to face new new
threats Ambassador mentioned hybrid
threats disinformation of course
terrorism that's that's already longer
story we face our neighbor not
hesitating to manifest openly
willingness to use force which means we
should respond very steadily and be
prepared military to to response as well
to respond as well so that's why this
format of NATO enhanced presence in that
Latvia Lithuania Estonia and Poland is
very strongly supported count current
concept by by our politicians by our
military on the other hand we do not
want to divide NATO as a security actor
from the from other international actors
present and active in Europe mostly
European Union and here we want to
combine our forces combined potential
which countries EU members and being at
the same time NATO members can can use
and for the for the good of the European
Union when when needs need arises
we observe and we support all the
efforts which are add and take under
taken recently to to make it possible to
better coordinate among EU members the
way we we built our capacities we
modernize our armies and we there is the
structure new relatively new structure
of permanent this is called pesco I will
always remember the short version but
not the long version making the full
name is permanent structured cooperation
it's not easy to understand how it works
I have to admit but the the basic the
fundament beyond this this this concept
is to allow allow us to coordinate
better and we can voluntary take promise
that we will let say modernize our air
force and it will be available for other
countries if need if it will be
necessary and the new part of that is
that this promise maybe should be
measured and should be executed I mean
this is not this is voluntary
contribution but legally binding we
cannot then after year after that no no
it was just you know political gesture
no it should be measured it should be
sure and available when time comes so
[Music]
that's one of the part we see we see in
practice this new involvement in in
securing European borders in military
Mediterranean Sea where there is a naval
force mission called Sofia acting
operating close to the Libyan coast and
there is also NATO mission acting there
and they are supporting each other which
is very very
that's one of the practical dimension
very visible and very practical and very
important right now
what what can I add
I was thinking also about OSCE
organization of Security Cooperation in
Europe which has of course completely
different nature taking its geographical
area the the membership of course much
bigger but currently with involvement of
a/c in Ukraine that's the only
international presence only reliable
source which allows us to to to see to
have reports from the region of conflict
in eastern Ukraine and it definitely
increases the role of a/c and much
stronger connects this organization as
well with our internal with our external
security policies so I guess I can stop
here and that's the very general picture
similar to my dear colleague and we'll
be open for the questions Thank You
Paolo thank you thank you for the issues
you raised of course it would be very
important during the discussion to
understand how the mechanism of
coordination is working to harmonize the
projects coming from NATO and European
Union and now I am giving the floor
very well his vision from Estonia
sitting in the United States I can't oh
I see right here so again thank you all
very much for coming we're Estonia's
permanent representative to the United
Nations mr. Sen your concern here he
would likely point out that this week
marks the 15th anniversary of Estonia as
well as laughing the thing becoming
members of NATO Estonia's Ministry of
Foreign Affairs emphasizes that the
country's strong commitment to NATO
recognizing it as the main guarantor of
its security Russia's annexation of
Crimea in 2014
pushed Estonia to increase defense
spending and beginning in the year 2012
Estonia has spent 2% and Kanyon
continues to do so this year slightly
over 2% of its GDP on defense and has
been taking part in NATO peacekeeping
missions since 1995 from 2014 to the
present there have been there has been
an increase in the number of countries
contributing to NATO's Baltic Air
Policing policing mission which protects
the airspace of the three Baltic
countries these missions are performed
from bases in ameri Estonia which is not
far from Tallinn and shio lie in
northern Lithuania Estonia foreign
ministry adds it just gives a little bit
of context of the the dedication and
commitment Estonia has these
international institutions particularly
NATO in the course of the past 10 years
we Estonia have rendered development in
humanitarian aid totaling over 25
million euros Estonia has security
cooperation with such important NATO
partners as Ukraine in Georgia
and also with Afghanistan and Iraq in
the last 10 years approximately 2,800
servicemen from the Estonian Defence
Forces participated in foreign missions
today there are hundreds Toni an
Estonian servicemen taking part in nine
field operations in five countries and
including some 40 servicemen in the NATO
resolute support mission in Afghanistan
we are convinced that such operations
ensuring peace and stability are an
important component of maintaining
international security and we intend to
maintain our participation at the in
them at the current level at a minim
minimum given Estonia's very small size
and population is just a hundred 1.3
million people its defense ultimately
rests on other states commitment to come
to collective defense and to article 5
of The Washington treaty the North
Atlantic Treaty Estonia is home to the
NATO cooperative cyber defence centre of
excellence this was established in 2008
this organization with personnel from a
number of countries analysts and
educators from the military government
academia and Industry conducts research
holds live-fire cyber defence exercises
as well beginning last year it is
responsible for identifying and
coordinating education and training in
cyber defence for all parts of NATO so a
mention mentioned by Professor excuse
I'm sorry head Bassett Erbil Kovich was
made earlier of Estonia's being subject
to cyber attacks in 2007 Estonia was
subjected to a significant cyber attack
from Russia on this was directed against
institutions of government security
media and finance there's significant
cooperation between Lafayette
Lithuania and Estonia on defense there's
a joint Baltic Defense College in
thought though Estonia
operated and financed by the three
countries defence ministries and there's
a joint Baltic battalion both bat and
infantry an entrance free battalion
based in [ __ ] Latvia that is part of
NATO's Defence Force it should also be
noted that beyond the area of Defence
Baltic Cooperation in political matters
perhaps leaves some expectations
unfulfilled much greater attention at
lease in Estonia is however paid to
participation in all possible
international organizations there's
there is a developing closer sense in
the three countries of a shared North
European identity you're speaking
I know I can say at least four Estonian
I believe in life the case applies to
Latvia and Lithuania as well as shared
cents a share cents of North European
identity between the Baltic countries
with the Nordic countries though firm
and persevering political ties could
also see greater development and
resilience there is a Council of Baltic
states however Latvian political
scientist Downey's outers concludes that
the primary identity framework for
citizens in the Baltic States remains
Baltic rather than Nordic European or
something else perhaps there is momentum
he writes the Baltic states are
gradually shifting north and west away
from Russia a process that Russia's
annexation of Crimea has hastened
Estonia knows it above all needs friends
in Europe that share its views last
month the chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee in the Estonian parliamentary
keikaku mr. Marco Mickelson in remarks
in the parliament said this about
Estonia security at a time when Russia
is attempting to use force to expand its
own borders in China has as its aim to
become a global leader
there is simply no alternative but close
cooperation and vigorous joint efforts
with the nation states of the European
Union the peace that reigns in Europe
only confirms the essential role that is
played by NATO's Washington treaty and
article 5 within it he added that there
is dangerous uncertainty and tensions
within the Western alliance and these
could potentially cause cooperation to
weaken or even lead to the
disintegration of NATO and these remarks
he just made four weeks ago in the
Estonian Parliament for Estonia and for
its security such such an image the
disgrace
disintegration of NATO would spell
disaster the end of the security is it
has assiduously worked for since the
restoration of its independence in 1991
thank you thank you
I spoke to ambassador of Estonia I
invited him to the panel so there now
they are in a serious process to be to
be elected to the Security Council as
well so competing with the friendly
nation of Romania for this seat well I
wish them both well to find a solution
House
and he apologized it not to be with us
but Brett exactly discovered the major
points of the Estonian policy has to be
security so let's start some some times
some exchange some particular important
issues to understand what's going on so
particularly during the last couple of
years in Europe the idea of the
reconstruction of the architecture
appeared even some of the countries they
raise the idea to have the European army
recently the idea was sounded again on
the top level during the Munich
conference on security my question is
very simple what is wrong who is the old
European security architecture why the
wish reshuffling is needed you know I
will start and maybe I'll start my
answer by answering to your first
question about why Latvians and
Estonians and Poland have been so
decisive upon the moment of regaining of
independence going away from neutrality
from non-alignment and I think first of
all this is our bitter historical
experience of the Soviet and Nazi
occupations when we lost our legitimate
place but at the international table we
were mentioned at the moment of the
dissolution of the League of Nations in
1945 the last time is in international
entities but but of course we were not
invited to San Francisco to create the
UN and and this very clear position as I
said is based on the notion of Europe
whole free and at peace we we fully
committed to that not only to the UN
Charter but to the Paris charter of
Voisey in 1990 that we fully reject any
notion of the spheres of influence
we fully reject any we rejected for more
than a decade offers from Russia about
cross guarantees there were proposals
that the US Germany and Russia could
provide the kind of cross guarantees to
the Baltic States and we said thank you
very much we were very clear and we
don't please don't be confused on the
one level we are probably the most
strongest proponents of regional
cooperation in the world and Baltic
region is probably one of the most
integrated in the world we are the
biggest trade partners among ourselves
we are members of currency we are in
terms of cross-border acquisitions
takeovers this is the most homogeneous
region except Russia and Belarus we are
internal fully internal part of the
European Union we are Finland and Sweden
are privileged partners of NATO we would
love to see them in the NATO family one
day but of course that's up to the to
the governments and people's of those
countries so we are proponents of
regional regionalism modern regionalism
and integration but we are very strongly
against division of European security
space we think that this is disastrous
proposal this is historically we have
seen disastrous mistakes and crimes
committed with division dividing of
European security space and maybe one
more aspect of course is the attitude to
history in Latvia we in the Baltics
we've been dealing a lot with the
uncovering the whole truth of the world
wars of the Soviet occupation of your
Nazi occupation of the collaboration of
the Holocaust very difficult very
controversial
painful unpleasant a lot of crimes have
been committed on our soil during those
tragic events but we did it when it
comes to our big neighbor to Russia the
process hasn't happened and with this
kind of attitude of Russia even before
Russian invasion against Ukraine we we
had been thinking very clearly that we
have to build this European future
security architecture together with
democratic countries which are open
towards past which are committed to the
same values rule-based international
order and ready to defend that coming
specifically to your second question we
don't think that fundamentals are wrong
of course we all have to invest in our
security in that sense we agree with
President Trump that 2 percent is the
necessary threshold it's it's not right
that quite the number of NATO allies is
not paying enough for defense and
defense means defense there is no you
defense and NATO defence armed forces
are the same defense budgets are the
same and we are we don't believe much in
a notion more for less
you cannot do more with the less
resources of course in the times of
economic contraction and Road economic
crisis we had to do it
2008 when we had quite a dramatic
economic downturn but this is not
sustainable in the long run so we think
that all countries should contribute in
the spending and I think we have
substantiated this with numbers we are
all in a two percent Club when it comes
to spending but of course we could do
more within Europe in terms of the
building of the interoperability but
please don't forget that in European
Union we have
very diverse countries with different
backgrounds we have Malta with specific
security policy outlook we have Ireland
with triple lock policies so they cannot
do anything unless unless there is
Security Council resolution at all this
is almost in the Constitution and and of
course we have Sweden and Finland which
is a bit different situation so we think
foundations are solid and right but of
course we in order to perpetuate our
alliances of course we have to deliver
on the implementation of the Summit
declarations we should implement fill
those niche capabilities which are
missing we should we should prove to
everyone that NATO is not a paper tiger
that this is really a living organism
and we do it by enlargement and we are
doing also that by deepening and working
with with European Union of course I
haven't mentioned also this Turkey and
Cyprus relationship which sometimes
complicates agreement on some political
issues but I think we are creative
enough and to work maximum possible and
to deliver to our to our nation's
security question was why we think now
about something called tur not've to
NATO European army or this kind of ideas
so we cannot pretend that we don't see
the elephant in the room I mean we live
now in a different climate than we been
five years ago and then we've been in
the thinking about security policy about
transatlantic relations for a very long
time
and discontinuity of thinking of this
discard this feeling of security of the
currently of the of the continuity of
this architecture this times are maybe
not over but this the scenario of change
became much more possible so we the
transatlantic the the European security
which is based on transit transatlantic
relations in fact is based on the
involvement of the United States with
the United States asking rightly about
more involvement from Europe and
signaling a big readiness to quite
drastically change its involvement it it
builds definitely new dynamics new way
of thinking about all the all the
architecture so I guess it's it's one of
the reasons why right now some of the
the European countries some of the
leading European countries are seriously
considering these scenarios what if we
will have to take care about our own
security just you know if transatlantic
relation will be much more with much
weaker so that's that's definitely I
guess maybe obvious maybe clear but
definitely worth to mention reason why
we think about differently yeah I agree
that the general security environment
has changed and both the European Union
and NATO first they are changing
adapting to the new realities NATO has
changed for the couple of last year's
dramatically well coming back to the to
the background what it was created for
two different values where do you want
to or women
okay okay okay thank you
so more we had more you had what is the
biggest challenge in the region in terms
of military-political everybody's
conventional war challenge or nuclear
threats or you understand what I'm
speaking about because the deployment of
new nukes in occurring Grodd well with
intermediate-range coverage and middle
range coverage and disagreements between
the United States and Russia on this
treaty what does it mean for the
security so conventional military
political challenge or nuclear threat or
what is more challenging or both of them
well if I may start we believe that the
most palpable threat is hybrid we study
very carefully the trend this trend for
the last have been studying for the last
10 years and just just a few examples
lately we had the military NATO military
drills in one of the native countries
and with the permission of one military
force of an atonement member country I
will not disclose the name we simulated
interaction with the soldiers of the
attempt unit through social media and
believe me or not but the soldiers left
their positions as as simple as that
and there are similar issues related to
the black-market of the social media
with the weaponization of the artificial
intelligence
using of the robots I don't know if this
is a have been discussed in this
auditorium or not but for instance when
it comes to Estonia to certain topics
not to every topic but a couple of years
ago close to 80% of the social media
materials in Estonia have been
registered that they are produced by
robots not by real people when things
have been exposed now on certain
subjects numbers have gone down to 60
and 40% but when it comes to elections
when it comes to political decisions
when it comes to their political
discourse in our countries in our
democracies we see we see not only
positive and light elements related to
social media but certain shadow and
certain vulnerabilities and we certainly
are interested in raising the public
awareness raising awareness of our
general public at our schools we start
to be published special books for for
for young students to understand
consequences and interconnections
between between cyber and manipulation
and media literacy and etc we see those
sort of more acute vulnerabilities and I
can leave with you a few brochures from
the Latin Riga based NATO Center of
Excellence dealing with those issues we
have seen that major companies media
platforms dealing with social media are
not really interested in in hi hygiene
the kind of cyber hygiene some of them
based they
this models are based in tactics or
abuse of those tools and and for for a
price of the lunch you can you can you
can on the one hand simulate I don't
know 10 100 likes on on your on your
Twitter account and you can simulate
hostile attacks on on some of your or
media platforms so very inexpensive very
dangerous malicious acts can be done and
can produce an incite violence that can
be done against armed forces it can be
done against minorities and could be
done in peacekeeping situations and we
should be we should be really vigilant
about them
when it comes to conventional threats we
believe that our region is quite well
covered enhanced forward presence it
works we have we are fine-tuning we need
to find you in certain things
of course we as I said we would love to
have Finland and Sweden in NATO that
would be a kind of strategic decision
which was fully consolidate security in
the Nordic Baltic space but but even
without that we are working very nicely
but from our point of view the biggest
gender danger is these frozen and non
frozen conflicts in Ukraine in Moldova
in Georgia and we certainly urge our
friends allies and partners in all
international organizations to not to
take those conflicts as a kind of fete
accompli we we need to focus all
political attention to
to deal with this very dangerous
conflicts which might get escalated any
any time and which men made they are not
they could be easily avoided in the past
and they could be resolved if there is a
political will in in in in Moscow to
solve those conflicts I think we are
making small progress in the Balkans
with accession of North Macedonia we did
enlargement to Montenegro of course we
still have Bosnia to to proceed with
membership action plan but but the
biggest danger is those Ukraine Georgia
Moldova which which which people are
being dying every day and and we have
not been able to stop to stop them thank
you agree about the warfare we are
experiencing it in Ukraine so and the
core of this danger is that uncertainty
uncertainty when from where and who we
will practice this hybrid approach
either it is about the cyber attack or
it is informational check or it is green
man without insignia
or it is a conventional threat not using
but just afraid having the tanks on the
borders of something or deploying of
nukes so but our experience says that it
could be used simultaneously all of them
so and uncertainly of this type of the
new war is very very dangerous so you
want something
at I guess that in the cyber question we
focus right now on this is a soft cyber
attacks maybe soft in the sense these
are attacks on people Minds the attacks
to to be to build divisions visible
everywhere not only in Europe now it is
more silent about cyber threats coming
to the infrastructure which I guess of
the Equality equal importance and the
very serious consequences when we think
about you know infrastructure
communication hospitals our systems are
so much based now on on digital
interconnection that it I guess we
shouldn't forget about data and
definitely that's very very vulnerable
area you use the term Western values and
both of you have been speaking about
environment all of you about environment
changes including cyber so my question
is what what can smaller states do in
their international role in helping to
maintain collective security smaller
states could be seen as subjects of the
the whims of these larger states and
their their their their vacillations in
Western values that an argument could be
made and their their difficulty in in
dealing with these environmental threats
that are emerging from their own
territories what should smaller state
smaller states do if it was if once use
you suffer to experience some kind of
the attack yeah becoming expert look
what happened was Estonia in 2007 and
the story became first ever partner of
NATO to establish the cyber center of
excellence Latvia is the leader in the
European Union well to bring first-ever
this
of Europe only on the combat against the
disinformation Finland is a good partner
you're absolutely right
let's back look back to the experience
of Finland to understand why they are
hosting the center of the hybrid wafer
and Finland so these these countries in
involving States they're well prepared
for that just based on their experience
and they are leading because they have
experience they know how so Perry sir do
we is there evidence that that these for
example the center that and I mentioned
it in Estonia there it is never
mentioned in this country but is there
evidence that in other farther places in
Europe in Britain I don't know in
Germany in Spain that that we have these
allies these people in other parts of
Europe and their lives mattered to us
right there their part we are we share
some values it's it's the weakening of
those values that sense of shared Ness
and then we're in this together to
secure guarantee our security that has
been the biggest problem and the short
answer to your question is that NATO was
created to defend common values well it
it worked during the Cold War then we
entered the post Cold War period when
values were substituted by interests
another question is how to bring values
back how to bring values back and to and
to build this partnership based on
values what are the values where they
are why disappeared interests are
playing I mean if I may complement a
little bit I think size is not the
decisive thing speaking about the
subjects of our today's discussion most
important is whether the sort of
countries experience is relevant to
others and in case of the Baltic States
Estonia Latvia Lithuania the the most
interesting is that we we are we have
been we are probably the one of the most
recent successful laboratories of change
metaphorically speaking we jumped from
singing revolution in the digital
revolution and considering our
historical background
we are borderline as in geographical
location we are borderline errs between
Europe and Eurasia with Soviet
experience we border Russia and Belarus
so we telescope development very rapidly
and we have accumulated quite unique
experience of dealing with the only
forms very early stages with the threats
coming from cyber from hybrid and we
have accumulated this experience of of
resilience if you want just to
substitute what I'm talking about
in Estonia speaking about a digital
platform as the selling selling
proposition is very simple as citizen in
Estonia with electronic ID card can do
anything online without only but two
things you cannot get married you cannot
divorce you still have to show up with
real person and the second thing you
cannot buy real estate and you cannot
sell it you still have to show with real
documents to avoid fraud the rest and
this is has been going for years more
than 10 years with one electronic ID
with one pass code you get prescription
drugs you you can do any kind of
licenses you do your taxes and you can
even vote in local elections in
Parliament elections in Latvia you can
do the same but you cannot vote in
Estonia Estonians have gone even further
and by doing all those things
since 1991 our countries have have
learned how to deter cyberattacks they
learned how to keep the vigilance of the
people and how to accommodate the pace
of Technology growth and and the
application of those tools by the
general public and those centers run in
Tallinn Riga those are not no national
centres there are NATO countries and
NATO partner countries for instance
Sweden and Finland they are
participating in those centres so all
like minded nations are welcome and this
is a sort of another university if you
want where we share our best practices
and we raise we try to raise also public
awareness within a UN as well not every
country is like-minded in the UN but we
are open to talk about the general
things we don't expect new conventions
on the UN soon but we think that some
ethical protocols and some understanding
of the risks and dangerous should be
should be shared by a by everyone
because at the end of the day this is
also could contribute to as DG's
sustainable development goals we're
really serious about achieving them
thank you it's a really great experience
from cyber defence to cyber deterrence
really really great experience now I
would like to give a flow to audience
please be concise speak on the topic of
our roundtable and you have a chance to
speak on other topics after this
roundtable
focus on NATO based on your historical
experience obviously and so I assume
that NATO membership is much more
essential than the European Union
membership and coming back to ambassador
Adamski's the elephant in the room
considering the fact that the president
Trump views the European Union as a foe
so how do you both of you how do you
reconcile these discrepancies if you
will or contradictions and and to
ambassador political which you are
you're using you raise your currency and
what are your measures to prevent
further Russian money laundering by
Danish banks in Latvia thank you well on
the first question I it is obvious that
we have some disagreements with this
administration we have climate we have
Human Rights Council we have some Golan
Heights most recent announcement but I
can say it putting a hand on the stack
of the Bibles when it comes to security
and defense NATO is working just fine
it's operational it's it's it's the only
game in the town if you want European
Union due to the complexity of the
decision of the members due to the
historical legacy we are still while we
are not making baby steps but we are
still in a very very early stage and
that doesn't mean that we should not
think about it when it comes to Latvia
we would be already we are participating
in almost every initiative by the
European Union but just one example
European battle groups have not been
used once they have been created they
have been existed on paper they have had
some training limited training but they
have never been used for political
reasons we have never had European
consensus at Foreign Affairs Council we
don't have military planning units
sufficient for significant operations we
can do some peacekeeping but but we
haven't had the real fighting experience
together on a pan-european EU level that
doesn't mean that we should not look
into that we probably should but if we
do that it should be gradual it should
be open of course to everyone but not
everyone is on board even in this new
structured cooperation three countries
have opted out and to be very blunt we
still have to see brexit outcome because
we don't know exactly is Britain in or
out we of course we will would like to
keep as close partnership with UK no
matter what but but there is a
difference if UK is part of Union or not
so we I think we believe we believe in
NATO we have to do more on European
things but European in our eyes
European things are remaining it's calm
mentoree total to do that to the second
question we agree that there are there
is significant homework which has to be
done by our domestic regulators and
banking community but but the same goes
for overall oversight in Europe and
globally as well because just one
example when we joined euro five years
ago and when we delegated some of the
competences to ECB in Frankfurt for
instance one example for largest
commercial banks in every you member
state under supervision from Frankfurt
this is in the law but but when when you
have a fire then we discover that there
are issues which ECB is taking on their
issues which ECB says we don't have
capacity or we don't do nitty-gritty of
the oversight this is has to be done by
the local authorities so we think that
in the future we will have to do a bit
of fine-tuning of any European
regulation as well but of course the
biggest homework still has to be done by
by by our national authorities and I
think speaking more globally there is
also a quite important process on the
hill in Washington DC when it comes to
shell companies when it comes to
offshore
oversight on a on a global level because
things what I'm talking about cannot be
immunized and fixed only in the in the
Baltics or within euro euro area if it's
not addressed on on a bigger level by by
legislators in the United States as well
because because this is like a sort of
global phenomena thank you the questions
was relating to the elephant and and yes
it's it's true there of course in the
European Union the degree of friendship
or controversy with bilateral well in
within the bilateral relations with
Washington will be will be different in
you in different cases Poland is
perceived and is acting also in reality
as one of the strongest allies of the US
and it's not always easy especially with
the Miss Commons security and foreign
and security policy such cases like Iran
coming to mind where we try to are try
to underline the underline the question
of values really values which we which
are on which we have built our our
transatlantic community and
which means we should do everything not
to weaken this come this this
values-based connection between USA and
in Europe and of course it doesn't mean
that we always will be we always have to
act visibly Washington with with the
relations with Washington us as a very
United group that's not rule that we
will be much eager to have stronger US
military presence in our country than
some other countries which will not take
it into account at all so maybe that's
only this shortcoming thank you
questions few more questions gentlemen
again thank you for sharing with us your
insights on these issues my question
pertains to in Ukraine the Donbass and
Crimea the Russian Federation utilized
for justification of their operations
the protection of ethnically Russian and
russian-speaking people looking across
your security space are there any other
areas that other let for example Narva
in Estonia what are some of the other
areas that you feel are at risk and what
actions are you taking to ensure that
that justification cannot be used again
in the same security space when it comes
to our relations with Russia of course
we don't chew we don't choose our
neighbours we don't shake and change the
geography and when we we are fully
cognizant that Russia is a big country
and and over the last 28 years we have
been trying to build up relations with
Russia we solved a few significant
leftovers
from the Soviet fifty years of Soviet
presence we managed to withdraw about
40,000 Russian troops last troops left
in the end of August 1998
it took we were the last country to
remove very significant military
infrastructure and present and footprint
we solved the border issue with Russia
we were the first Baltic states which
fully delineated the demarcate border
with Russia we accepted the de facto
border upon the moment of restoration of
independence Joseph Stalin three times
changed border to the advantage of
Russia in the 40s it was difficult
debate in the public in the Parliament
but we accept it for the for the future
of their of the of our relations you are
right we have the biggest ethnic Russian
non Latvian population in the Baltic
States it's about 28 percent we've been
for 30 years we've been trying to
integrate them into our society we
largely we think we largely succeeded
when we regained independence 80% of
non-ethnic Latvians didn't speak the
language of the country now the ratio is
the opposite 80% of non that means
proficient reasonably proficient 20 15
percent mostly elderly people they're
still struggling but we try we tried
it's not easy process but we tried to
involve them in the society we try to
facilitate naturalization of these
people and we are building coherent
political nation open
we still fund public education in eight
languages
including Russian and Belarusian and
Polish and Ukrainian etcetera we try to
do it gradually I think quite quite
successfully for I should touch the wood
but for 30 years since the regaining of
independence we have not had any act of
inter-ethnic violence in let me the rate
of interesting marriages is one of the
highest more than 20%
it used to be higher in the Balkans but
after the Balkan wars its considerably
down in the Baltics in latter it's still
fairly high heaven we have about 60
agreements with Russia most of them are
functioning our bilateral trade is about
12% used to be 95 before independence
now it's about 12 so we are not we are
not we're still buying Russian gas but
technically we can buy a Norwegian or
British gas as well so and in a couple
of years we will fully disintegrate from
the from the electricity network with
Russia and with support of Poland we
will I think by 21 22 we will have also
fully gas grid fully connected with the
Finland and Poland so all in all senses
umbilical cords will be cut from from
the old Soviet systems of course that
doesn't mean that Russia technically
cannot use any kind of false on bogus
pretext for pressures they have been
using that in that sense we have built
up this resilience for quite a while and
we try to respect respond by clearly
stating our objectives by doing
comprehensive integration into Western
structures by educating our society of
course we have been trying to raise also
our living standards and currently it is
in all three countries higher than in
Russia so that there is no appeal for
Eurasian integration in in the Latin
society and as we have seen in the last
elections in October last year the
appeal of the sort of Russian political
parties is fading gradually continuously
every four years they get less and less
votes European Parliament elections are
coming in May last time they had to sort
of pro-moscow pro-russian members in
European Parliament my prediction that
this time we'll have less most likely
one but I might be wrong but these are
the answers and of course military
presence clarity that every time Russian
pilots eye in the skies over the Baltic
Sea they are meted and greeted by native
planes the same goes with with navy and
same goes with anything else so I think
this is the in that sense this is a
beauty of the current architecture that
everything is clear everything is
understood and we are talking about the
very very small geographic region this
is not Pacific this is not Kazakhstan
where the fly time between the Baltic if
we are talking about supersonic planes
it's this is seconds and minutes and the
margin of error is is very small so in
the case of Latvia we never had any
violations
of our territory or our airspace for 30
years we hope that every decision maker
is is is taking those all those elements
in consideration so we don't we don't
expect classical conventional threats
more threat is more real with
manipulations of social media with cyber
attacks which are which which is almost
everyday phenomena ok so thank you thank
ambassador yeah two important issues you
raised most probably we will discuss
during the informal meetings those who
have an interest in that energy energy
security is really the part of the art
or the whole architecture of European
Union and so you know how we are trying
to be independent fully independent
working within yourself when thinking
how to have the the new nuclear power
station to build how do you have the
diversity of the of the delivery of
energy second what is very important you
you raise know answering the question of
of the student here what what brings the
stability in all Baltic states high
levels living standards comparable to
neighbors if you look at all the indexes
of the human development economics in
Europe Poland and Baltic States there on
the top on the top so and this brings
some kind of the of the stability of
course the they have a challenge because
it is not a crisis but is a phenomena
people are looking the better the better
places to live so unfortunately there is
there is a migration process people are
moving ahead
and that's why to bring to normalize
that to balance the situation of course
Europe should also care about that and
not to not a push the idea of two-speed
Europe but to well to bring equality in
in the distribution of the of the pooled
part of the pooled
sovereignity to the to the brussels so
that's why we don't understand this this
dialogue between them and the brussels
well how to how do how do these
stability more sustainable how to keep
raising the standards stories doing the
fantastic things and the rest as well so
most probably this keeps people from the
neighboring neighboring chronic
countries to move there across the Narva
River they're comparing where it's
better they prefer to move to the other
side thank you very much for accepting
the invitation thank you for your
presentation thank you for this exchange
we'll have some more time for informal
believe me so the audience is well
prepared for that to speak on on
whatever they want to do we have to have
more information and to bring into the
to the students to their classes and
thank you again and Brad thank you for
hosting this event thank you and I
invite you to the to the next
[Applause]
[Music]
you